العربيه هي منبر عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل
للسعوديين والعالم العربي من خلال هذا
المنبر
[موسيقى]
بعد الاعلان وفي اللقاء وقالت تحقق ما
يزيد عن ترليون ونصف ريال اذا استهدفنا
شيء ولا فيها برامج تنفيذيه
[موسيقى]
في رؤيتها لعام 2030 تؤمن السعوديه بان
ثروتها الحقيقيه تكمن في مجتمعها وافرادها
ريال 500 مليار ريال او اكثر في عشرين
عشرين عشرين ثلاثين سوف نصل الى ترليون
ريال سعودي في هذه الرؤى قد وضعنا
الاقتصاد السعودي خطوه على الطريق الصحيح
حمايه للاقتصاد من ناحيه القدره الحكوميه
على خلق ايرادات لا تتاثر بسعر النفط
[موسيقى]
مدينه فرصه ننتقل الى جيل جديد عن طريقه
الحياه من المدن من التقنيات فكل عناصر
نجاح موجوده خلق شيء عظيم وشيء جديد واهم
عنصر لدينا هو الشعب السعودي
الفرق الذي سوف يكون من يوم كازون
داخل اليوم مثل الفرق بين هذا الهاتف وبين
هذا الهاتف
[موسيقى]
ليوم وجهه المستقبل مشروع جديد اعلن عنه
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
هو المشروع الاول من نوعه عالميا
والمستثمرون شركاء في صياغه انظمته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دوله تريد ان تنوع الاقتصاد هذا المشروع
يستهدف تسع قطاعات اقتصاديه ما زالت بكرا
تنتظر خطابه ودها من المستثمرين خالد
العمري العربيه كيف يجب ان نظر الى هذا
المشروع العملاق قياده سموه ولي العهد
طرحت مشروع حديث تماما في نوع كيف سيؤثر
مشروع عن يوم على وضع المملكه اقليميا
وسياسيا هذا ليس فقط مشروع اقتصادي وليس
فقط مشروع تنميه بل مشروع حضاري يدمج
مجتمعات عده جبال
الرغبه والاراده شعبيه القويه
[تصفيق]